all right here with more reaction Fox
News contributor kellyanne Conway you
know kellyanne I often say that
Democrats circle the wagons Republicans
create uh circular firing squads all
right so this is what's going to be
interesting to me this week when we have
this impeachment inquiry vote will
Democrats that maybe don't want Joe
Biden to be their candidate in
2024 do you see them maybe using this as
an opportunity to vote with Republicans
to slow push Joe off the ticket it's
possible and I think it's going on with
the mainstream media and they're polling
Sean why are CNN and NBC and other
outlets that endorse Joe Biden don't
want Donald Trump to be president again
running all these polls that show
historically High unfavorability rating
for Joe Biden High unfavorability rating
on his handling the economy energy crime
the Middle East Ukraine the Border you
name it so I think these Democrats in
Congress either through their silence
which should be seen as acquiescence or
they're voting with Republicans to move
forward on an impeachment inquiry are
answering your question for you they're
taking the advice of people like me who
tell Democrats all the time if I were a
Democrat I'd roll the dice get rid of
Biden and Harris and just take my
chances because they're going to ruin
the future of the party you know Sean if
there's nothing to see there if there's
truly no evidence the Democrats should
welcome the inquiry maybe would help Joe
Biden the polls they'd see him as a
victim they'd see him as put upon they
can say it's a partisan Witch Hunt they
know Joe Biden has very little of any
political currency going into this
impeachment inquiry and they know this
is a white house that has stonewalled
and is non-compliant with the simplest
of subpoenas that's why I think you're
going to see Democrats come forward they
should come forward Sean and they should
say with dignity and transparency I want
the White House to at least comply with
an inquiry Sean we lived through
conclusions in search of evidence all
during the Trump candidacy presidency
and frankly post presidency there is
Russia collusion we will find it
sometime somewhere they still haven't
years later we have more Russia
collusion more Ukrainian collusion with
the bidens than we do with Trump so if
they don't fear if there's nothing to
fear go for it I think Biden is in such
deep trouble though in all this polling
for the Wall Street Journal poll to have
Trump beating him for the first time in
its Poll for Trump to be beating Biden
on
22% by 22% on people say the economy is
the number one issue to them that spans
all demographic and Geographic groups
and if you think it's not so bad for
Biden watch him take Hillary Clinton
with him on the campaign trail that will
really be the death nail she is a
two-time loser election denier the
second most popular person in a
two-person household every day when she
wakes up and in 2022 one or two
candidates wanted her with wanted her
with them Kathy hokel in New York I
think he wants Barack Obama by his side
he's going to get the cheap uh version
of that Hillary Clinton all right let me
ask you this so as we go into
2024 you know the old saying are you
better off than you were four years ago
that will be a question next year I
honestly and I mean objective as I can I
cannot think of a single policy success
uh uh any policy that has benefited the
American people of Joe Biden that's
number one number two if you look at Joe
Biden and and I think this is
interesting I can't think of a single
public event kellyanne not one where he
has not had some cognitive incident
either he mumbles he bumbles he fumbles
you can't understand him he's you know
incomprehensible uh or something like
what happened and I'll read it to you
I'll put it up on the screen again
verbatim because you can't make this up
in case you missed it it you know over a
billion 300 million trillion 300 million
okay I don't have an abacus like Joe
does I actually have a real computer you
know it's actually on my phone a
calculator
and all right how does he get away with
that day after day week after week and
nobody in the media seems to Care by the
way he does who cares hey Sean who cares
what the media thinks and does and
covers and lies about when the people
themselves are telling pollsters right
left and Center this guy's got to go
they have no faith in him whatsoever not
a single issue where Joe Biden is more
approved than disapproved in his
handling on the issue you name the issue
and these are public events where he has
teleprompters you're showing it right
there he's reading from a teleprompter
and he's making these flubs and gaffs
can you see him in a 90-minute debate
with Donald Trump when he is asked why
didn't you go to East Palestine Ohio why
did you kill those Keystone Pipeline
jobs on day one and punish 42,000
innocent Americans who either were or
could be working in those jobs why did
you uh chaotically pull pull out of
Afghanistan in August of 2021 why did
you do this that and the other in
Ukraine in the Middle East at the border
why are you letting 9 million people
through how in the world is he going to
have the agility and the Acuity and the
ability to actually do that without a
teleprompter on his own defending his
record I don't think he's getting away
with the thing I think the Democratic
party long term is is in a very bad
place by just hanging on to Biden and
Harris Shaw and what you see in the
polls now it's how people are going to
vote a year from now I promise you less
than a year from now because things
aren't going to change they are worried
about their own economic anxiety they
stopped worrying about his acurity and
his health they're worried about their
own economic wherewithal last Point
these new CNN polls nine 9% of people
under the age of 45 in Michigan and
Georgia said that Joe Biden is the kind
of president that aligns with their
policy positions young over a billion
over a billion 3 million trillion $300
million Dr Seuss lives and breathes in
Joe Biden I mean I think he'd get a a
big Applause in kindergarten for knowing
all those big words uh we all love
yellow school bus you got it we love
having you thank hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else